este martes las fuerzas israelíes
mataron a dos palestinos en la
cisjordania ocupada uno de ellos estaba
en la lista de los más buscados se trata
de ibrahim al nabulsi un alto comandante
de la brigada de los mártires de al-aqsa
el grupo militante terrorista vinculado
al partido gobernante de al fatá que
operan principalmente en cisjordania y
que la nación judía había empezado a
buscar a principios de este año debido a
una serie de tiroteos en esa misma zona
la policía rodeó la casa de al nabulsi
atrincherado en el interior se negó a
salir sin respuesta la policía abrió
fuego la eliminación del terrorista
ibrahim al nabulsi es otro paso en
nuestra lucha intransigente contra el
terrorismo felicitó la acción combinada
de las organizaciones de seguridad que
llevó a cabo una acción selectiva con
gran éxito y sin víctimas
además uniformados israelíes aseguran
que sus tropas fueron atacadas por
palestinos que arrojaron piedras y
explosivos por lo que sus efectivos
respondieron con disparos dejando
decenas de heridos
el enfrentamiento se dio tan solo dos
días después de que israel y la yihad
islámica palestina pusieran fin a un
combate de 3 días la franja de gaza
lo que está ocurriendo en nablús es una
agresión y el pueblo palestino tiene
derecho a enfrentarse a esta agresión y
a defenderse creemos que los asuntos en
cisjordania seguirán intensificándose a
menos que el mundo intervenga para poner
fin a la agresión y el terrorismo
israelí en nuestro pueblo
las redadas israelíes en cisjordania se
han intensificado en los últimos días
luego de que israel arrestar a uno de
los altos mandos de la yihad islámica
palestina en cisjordania y bloqueara el
acceso a la franja de gaza